[Music]
so apparently
haunted houses do not scare off new home
buyers according to a new study is it
because uh inventory is so low right now
i guess that's exactly what's going on
right they're like [ __ ] it if it's
haunted i'll buy it still a good price
they're saying that a lot of people
say that a major concern is not finding
out a house is haunted it has more to do
with
the price go figure that shit's haunting
um california property taxes that shit's
[ __ ] hunting living in california
haunting that's [ __ ] hunting so 44 of
respondents believe they live in a
haunted house 44 people believe they
live in a haunted house they think their
house is home the value goes up but i
want to know what kind of investigations
these people are doing what is
considered a haunting a lot of agents
say uh before like if someone passed
away in the house it was like a deal
breaker but now
some people don't even care anymore if
they could just get the house that they
want then they'll get i'll ask how they
were dead
like if they like if it's like an old
lady that just [ __ ] died i'm like
that's cool but if it's somebody that
blasts their [ __ ] old brains out or
someone goes what if they just
kidnapping
justice
no no no because then that's they're
gonna haunt what if the ghost plays
really loud music all the time [ __ ] you
insane
people don't think about that what era
though 18th century
that's whack i mean if it's like
nickelodeon piano that's dope but you
know even that statistic of 44 of people
think their houses are haunted that's
probably not even accurate like remember
all the ghost hunters episodes where
they would do that show like half more
than half something just trust me bro
yeah they were like oh [ __ ] they're
making [ __ ] up or like those they'll see
shadows like oh it's a shadow and it's a
car reflection every single time they
think they're [ __ ] you never
fantasized about being seduced by a
ghost of course i thought i think about
ghosts blowing me all the [ __ ] time
do you think that'd be pleasurable [ __ ]
yeah well i mean i can't feel nothing
but apparently have a cold touch so it'd
be kind of weird i don't know dude you
ever had um a girl put like listerine
strips in her mouth before she sucked
your dick no i have not i don't think it
fully changes the temperature that much
but i mean probably more for her doesn't
her dick burn have you ever had a girl
drink ice water and
drink some suck some dick
continue have you ever had a girl have
you ever ever had a girl [ __ ]
put some ice in her mouth and suck your
dick have you ever had a girl get a root
canal and immediately suck your dick
right
because you haven't lived because it's
called
it's called fire and ice okay
and what they do is they have hot tea or
hot water okay and then they have ice
water and then they switch back and
forth was the last time you did this
with a girl yeah you know this very well
and where did you learn about this this
was in beijing china in the winter of
2006 for real and you got a fire and ice
treatment yeah i didn't know what was
happening until my friend told me what
that it was he was in the next did you
pay for the service i did it my friend
paid for it are you wearing a condom at
this time
what do they call it
i don't know
they were talking and they were talking
in chinese
they were talking in chinese and i don't
know what was happening before it
happened was your body like yo enjoy the
fire announcement
i'll see you after
this [ __ ] no but we were talking during
the whole time it was happening because
you could hear it's kind of like a in
different it's like paper wall so what i
just was like what's happening i'm like
she's using hot water i'll just get it
from one to ten ten being the best thing
ever what would you rate it on a
scavenger oh it's like up there with ten
dude i was shocked did you find that i
was weird when we're in the room there
was a stove right next to the fridge
there wasn't a stove but there was she
came in with drinks and i thought that
was for me to drink after she goes no
i think you have a slight smirk i feel
like there's a really like enjoyable
moment in your life why don't you do it
again yeah exactly i never i just never
remembered so i'm going to ask for it
you asked for that how long did this uh
sexual act last it's not a sexual act
man she's stuck in his dick
spiritualized your [ __ ] day god
you're weird it's a massage there's a
massage part of it yeah yeah but also
like how long did that last he wants to
know how long you last dude what if i
want to try it you know not even a
minute dude
so all i'm saying is ice
on the dick is not a bad idea it sounds
like a really bad idea sounds like a bad
idea especially a foreskin it was just
actually yeah it was it was ice on her
mouth first and then my dick it's not
direct did you come to the cold or come
to the hot good question
where did you come down because you're
in beijing on a seat belt
but you come on
[Laughter]
yeah apparently the housing market you
know
way too many experiences
i wish i had more why are you talking
what are you just told me your crazy
experience you have a crazy experience
yeah drive by shooting bars or whatever
yeah i know i can come in a diagonal
whatever but like but i'm also like 10
years older than you no but it's just
like like i'm never going to be in
beijing china having eyes and stuff yeah
you [ __ ] yourself you're the one that
wanted to get engaged it's not me joe
you have the most you have to admit you
have the most unique experiences across
the board it's a sexual maverick as you
say yeah it's not even sexual just just
in general you've been to more
waterfalls than i've been yeah way more
water you want to come is waterfall if
you want to go out
the sexual act he stood in more
waterfalls than i have
if you want to come i'll take you
exactly i think i have to did you did
your wife tell you i saw her at the park
she said you guys like walked a bunch
yeah alone
[ __ ] fire and she said she just kind
of fire and ice thing with you i didn't
know what that meant
that was starting to make sense and she
kept saying like yeah joe kept saying
just put only ice and just leave it on
his dick i'm trying to give her pointers
for you i guess she didn't [ __ ] do it
man
trying to help you live man sweet guy
so this is about ghosts did you did you
spend most of your time at home in your
life is that why
you don't feel like you lived enough
it's my family they uh they really
preach the whole like no vacation
they're very asian like we save money
save money so we never did anything no
vacations no road trips no nothing no
nothing
just to the catholic church and back on
sunday that was it no camping trip have
a ritual after catholic church at least
anything uh buffet really yeah how's
that what's sick what buffet uh golden
corral heard of it i love golden corral
dude wait they said they don't got money
have you heard of ryan's no it's like uh
what's that la one with the steak golden
corral is classic home crowds sizzler
sizzler like scissors do you remember
the vegas buffet in l.a yeah in glendale
yeah it was called the vegas buffet this
one in hollywood too
buy in and out
uh yeah it's like a cross street yeah
did you have a bucket list when you're
like when i'm free and i can do whatever
i [ __ ] want i'm doing it now i just
wanted to travel i just felt like i
couldn't travel why did you choose covet
times to travel dude no one's ever in
hawaii that's true no one's ever
anywhere you're right i've been enjoying
residents of haunted houses claim to
experience strange noises i've worked
hard on this article focus feelings of
being touched or watched
seeing strange shadows
or even ghosts and random hot or cold
spots throughout the house gilbert have
you ever seen a ghost yeah
don't tell us about it just say yeah
all right cool anyways uh anthony have
you ever seen a ghost i don't know are
you hey isn't vietnamese people like
hella like in the ghost [ __ ] yeah but i
mean a lot of easter eggs are people
aren't good when did you see the ghosts
what did you see
wait you're beating me chinese
vietnamese [ __ ] that just blew my mind
chinese my blood venus my culture my my
parents were born there 100 beijing
beijing what ghost did you see
yeah you mother
[ __ ] a piece of [ __ ] uh the banana
tree this was in uh savannah georgia
i did a ghost tour
when i did a ghost tour i swear to god
the guy kept talking about carriages
that you'll see them and i saw one i
don't know if because he implanted it in
my mind or not was it a real character a
ghost carriage a ghost carriage what the
[ __ ] are you talking about it's like a
horse's carriage but there's nobody
explaining like was it a [ __ ] pumpkin
or what dude oh man it was a [ __ ]
carriage with ghost horses yes with
those horses the whole thing was just a
outline i just saw an outline from a
distance basically where uh forest gum
that that area in savannah did it
disappear i just saw it go away so it
could have just been an actual carriage
and it was just a carousel
it was it was a [ __ ] like thinking
about it like it never never disappeared
it just went away was it translucent or
anything cool it looked translucent okay
this is a weak ghost story bro was it
that's why they said yes and it'll light
up first
no man now i think about it i think it
was just a light colored carriage it
didn't go it was a plan not trying to
put the energy in the universe but kind
of trying to put the energy in the
universe
seeing a [ __ ] ghost with a bunch of
homies is like the way like i hope
that'd be pretty cool i've never seen a
ghost i'd rather have a shared
experience by myself let's let's go
ghost hunting together didn't you do
that with casa no i didn't go i wasn't
yet i don't know let's go let's get the
boys we should all experience some [ __ ]
that's where where should we go though
where do you go start at deja vu in
hollywood and work our way out i heard
there's some haunted strip clubs
yeah
i want to investigate that's a brilliant
or the comedy story isn't that supposed
to be [ __ ] like notoriously there are
people there it's a comedy story bobby
claims that every time
people go to the bathroom there's these
dead comics that are just there in the
bathroom they talk to you they just talk
oh they're doing good i'm like these are
also just like comics other jokes to die
for
that that was good do the same joke joe
but do it your way is it jokes to die
for oh
sorry anthony carlos macias
sorry dude he told him he just does it
better
[Laughter]
[Music]
you